>>Tucker: WELCOME TO TUCKER
CARLSON TONIGHT.
IT'S DIRECTLY ACROSS FROM THE
HOT CALIFORNIA.
IT'S NOT THAT FAR FROM THE
STATES AND THAT'S A BAD THING
BECAUSE MEXICO AND THE PAIN NOW
BE THE SINGLE LARGEST PRODUCER
AND DISTRIBUTOR OF THE SYNTHETI
OPIOID FIT IN ALL.
CARTELS ARE MAKING IT IN MASS
QUANTITIES.
THEY'RE NOT MAKING IT FOR
DOMESTIC CONSUMPTION WITHIN
MEXICO.
THEY'RE MIXING MAKING IT TO
EXPORT HERE.
YOU CAN CYP RIGHT IN THE CAPITA
11 POUNDS OF SENTINEL SELLS FOR
AROUND $15,000 FOR IT IN THE
UNITED STATES THAT SAME AMOUNT
SELLS FOR MORE THAN $100,000.
YOU CAN SEE THE INCENTIVE.
HOW MUCH SENTINEL IS THAT?
JUST 2 MILLIGRAMS OF THE DRUG
CAN BE LETHAL TO A HUMAN BEING,
THAT MEANS 11 POUNDS CAN NEARLY
TO AND A HALF MILLION FATAL
DOSES OF SENTINEL.
AGAIN, THERE IS A MAJOR
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES FOR DRUG
CARTELS WHICH RUN HUGE PARTS OF
MEXICO TO PRODUCE THIS DRUG AND
SHIP IT NORTH.
IF KINKED COOKING WAS THE DRUG
OF THE 1980s WE ARE LIVING IN
THE NEW ERA AND THE NUMBERS SHO
IT.
THEY SEIZED AS TO POUNDS OF IT
TOTAL AT OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
COMPARE THAT TO WHAT WE'RE
SEEING NOW IN THE FIRST EIGHT
MONTHS OF THIS YEAR.
FIRST EIGHT MONTHS FOR THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT SEES MORE THAN 7,000
TO HUNDRED IS THE HIGHEST AMOUN
SEIZED BY FAR.
IT'S A SMALL PERCENTAGE OF THE
FENTANYL THAT CAME OVER THE
BORDER SINCE ITS BORDERLESS AND
DIFFICULT TO DETECT FREIGHT THE
U.S. SENTENCING COMMISSION.
SINCE FISCAL YEAR 2018 FOR THE
NUMBER OF FENTANYL OFFENDERS
DOUBLED EACH FISCAL YEAR
RESULTING IN A 3592 PERCENT
INCREASE.
FEDERAL AUTHORITIES RECENTLY
ANNOUNCED THAT THEY HAVE SEIZED
NEARLY 10 MILLION COUNTERFEIT
BILLS AND MANY OF THEM WERE
REPLACED WITH FENTANYL.
NEWS REPORTS FROM CHICAGO SAY
THAT FENTANYL HAS BECOME AN
EPIDEMIC.
>> THE PILL ON THE LEFT IS A
ANNEX BREAK THE ONE ON THE RIGH
IS COUNTERFEIT TO PRAY NOT
KNOWING THE DIFFERENCE CAN BE
DEADLY.
THE DRUG ENFORCEMENT
ADMINISTRATION WARNS OF A
DRAMATIC INCREASE IN FAKES OR
SCRIPTION PILLS FLOODING THE
MARKET FROM CRIMINAL DRUG
NETWORKS IN MEXICO.
THE DRUGS MADE TO LOOK LIKE
TOXIC OR ADDERALL ARE LACED WIT
FENTANYL OR METH.
THE DEA HAS SEIZED MORE THAN
9.25 AND COUNTERFEIT BILLS FOR
THE HEAD OF THE CHICAGO DIVISIO
SAY THEY HAVE SEIZED 600 POUNDS
OF FENTANYL.
>> THE RISE IN THE CONSUMPTION
OF FENTANYL MIRRORS THE RISE OF
THE AVAILABILITY OF FENTANYL.
WHICH IS CAUSING THE RISE IN
DEATHS BY OD.
ALL OF THAT AS A RESULT IN THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION'S
IMMIGRATION POLICY.
WHEN YOU OPEN THE BORDERS, IT'S
NOT JUST PEOPLE WHO COMES IN.
IT IS MASSIVE AMOUNTS OF
FENTANYL AND OTHER ILLEGAL DRUG
FOR THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
TELLS YOU THEIR BORDER POLICIES
IS HUMANE, BUT IT'S JUST THE
OPPOSITE SPREAD THAT POLICY HAS
RESULTED IN THIS COUNTRY
BECOMING FLOODED WITH FENTANYL.
IT'S RESULTING IN THE DEATHS OF
MANY THOUSANDS, MANY THOUSANDS
OF AMERICANS.
THE LATEST DATA FROM THE CDC
SHOWS THAT DRUG OVERDOSE DEATHS
IN THE UNITED STATES HIT A NEW
HIGH, ALMOST 100,000 DEATHS OF
AMERICAN CITIZENS DURING THE
TWELVE-MONTH PERIOD THAT ENDED
IN MARCH OF THIS YEAR.
HOW MUCH MORE IS THAT THAN LAST
YEAR?
AT 30 PERCENT INCREASE IN ONE
YEAR.
SO THERE ARE A LOT OF REASONS
THIS IS HAPPENING.
ONE OF THE MAIN REASONS IS
GOVERNMENT POLICY, WHICH IS MAD
THE POPULATION SEDENTARY AND
DEPRESSED RATES OUR GOVERNMENT
SPENT THE LAST YEAR I CAN
EVERYONE INSIDE THEIR HOMES FOR
THE RESULTS OF THAT IS THAT
DRUGS ARE EVERYWHERE, AND MAJOR
AMERICAN CITIES ARE
UNRECOGNIZABLE.
LOOK AT THIS REPORT FROM SAN
FRANCISCO LOCAL NEWS STATION.
>> THE RATE OF ACCIDENTAL DRUG
OVERDOSES AND HOSPITALIZATIONS
AND DUSK IS OUTPACING THE CITY'
EXPANDING TEAM OF CRISIS
INTERVENTION SPECIALIST.
FENTANYL HIGHLY ADDICTIVE OPIOI
MUCH CHEAPER THAN HEROIN ENTERE
THE DRUG MARKET A FEW YEARS AGO.
>> FENTANYL HAS BEEN A DRIVER
FOR THE INCREASE.
>> THE POWERFUL NARCOTIC WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR MORE THAN 500
DEATHS LAST YEAR AND HAS BECOME
THE DRUG OF CHOICE FOR MANY
USERS IN SAN FRANCISCO.
WE HAVE BEEN DOCUMENTING THE
EPIDEMIC REMONSTRATE MANY
EXPERTS BELIEVE THAT SOCIALIZED
RELATION FROM THE CORONAVIRUS
MAY BE CONTRIBUTING TO THE DEAT
TOLL.
>> WHAT WE REFERRED TO
HABITUALLY AS OUR HOMELESS
CRISIS WHICH IS BIGGER THAN IT'
EVER BEEN IN AMERICAN HISTORY I
NOT PRIMARILY ABOUT HOMES NOT
EVEN ABOUT MENTAL ILLNESS
STRICTLY SPEAKING.
IT'S MOSTLY ABOUT DRUGS.
AND DRUG ADDICTION.
NONE OF THIS SHOULD REALLY
SURPRISE US.
WE SPENT THE LAST YEAR DIVIDING
AMERICANS FROM EACH OTHER FOR
THE RESULT IS LONELINESS.
THE CLOSE LID CHURCHES AND THE
GEMS AND FORCE PEOPLE TO STAY
APART FROM THEIR FAMILY, FRIENDS
, AND THE PEOPLE THEY'RE
CLOSEST TO.
THE VERY SAME MOMENT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS OPENED THE
BORDER ALLOWING A MASSIVE WAVE
OF THIS HIGHLY ADDICTIVE DEADLY
SYNTHETIC OPIOID TO ENTER THIS
COUNTRY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK HAPPENED?
AND OFF A LOT OF PEOPLE DIED.
THIS WAS THE RESULT OF BAD
POLICY.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION ISN'T
TO BLAME FOR IGNORING THE
PROBLEM, THERE NOT APOLOGIZING
FOR IT OF COURSE FURTHER DOING
SOMETHING MORE DESTRUCTIVE
FURTHER MAKING IT WORSE.
THEY ARE MAKING IT LESS POSSIBL
FOR THE U.S. GOVERNMENT TO
CONTROL WHAT COMES ACROSS OUR
BORDER.
THEY BLOOM BORDER PATROL FOR
DARING TO PATROL ON HORSEBACK.
NOW THEY'D HAVE A VENUE IN
EXTREMIST TO LEAD THE CUSTOMS
AND BORDER PROTECTION.
HOW EXTREME?
DURING THE CONFIRMATION HEARING
IN CONGRESS YESTERDAY AGNES WAS
ASKED REPEATEDLY WHETHER WHAT
WAS HAPPENING AT THE BORDER WAS
A CRISIS AND REPEATEDLY HE
REFUSED TO SAY THAT IT WAS THE
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS
ARE DYING BECAUSE OF THIS BORDE
POLICY.
AND YET HERE IS THE MAN WHO THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WOULD LIKE
TO RUN THE BOARD OF.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE WE HAVE A
CRISIS AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER?
YES OR NO?
>> SENATOR, DOESN'T REALLY
MATTER WHETHER WE CALL IT A
MAJOR CHALLENGE, A CRISIS, A BI
PROBLEM?
>> DO WE HAVE A CRISIS AT THE
BORDER, YES OR NO?
>> LET ME ASSURE YOU THAT NO ON
BELIEVES THERE IS GREATER
URGENCY TO THIS MATTER THAN I DO
.
>> ARE YOU SAYING THERE'S NOT A
CRISIS AT THE BORDER?
>> NO, I DON'T THINK, I DON'T
SPEAK TO URGENT AND HAS NOT
SERIOUS AT ALL.
>> IS THERE A CRISIS OR IS THER
NOT A CRISIS AT THE BORDER?
>> SENATOR I WOULD SAY MY
HIGHEST PRIORITY.
>> I DIDN'T ASK YOUR PRIORITY.
I ASKED YOU TO CHARACTERIZE THE
SITUATION OF THE BORDER.
IS THERE A CRISIS AT THE BORDER?
>> WHAT I'M TRYING TO CONVEY IS
HOW SERIOUS I TAKE WHAT'S
HAPPENING AT THE BORDER AND THE
AMOUNT OF WORK I WANT TO PUT
INTO ADDRESSING A.
>> HERE IS A GUY TOTALLY
BEHOLDEN TO THE NGOS, MANY
FUNDED THAT CONTROL OUR
IMMIGRATION LESABRE AT HE SO
BEHOLDEN TO THAT HE CAN'T TELL
AN OBVIOUS TRUTH UNDER OATH FOR
FEAR OF OFFENDING THEM.
THEY ARE HIS REAL CONSTITUENCY,
NOT YOU OR ANYONE ELSE WHO LIVE
IN THIS COUNTRY.
IF THE RADICAL NGOS THAT WOULD
LIKE TO OPEN THE BORDER KNOWING
FULL WELL THAT DOING SO WOULD
RESULT IN THE DEATHS OF MANY
THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS FROM THE
DRUGS THAT ARE ALSO COMING
ACROSS THE BOARD OR.
OUR LEADERSHIP CLASS IS SO
LACKING THAT THEY DON'T EVEN
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT DRUG USE AS A
PROBLEM OR A CRISIS AS THEY
REFUSED TO SAY.
TH